THE STATE OF FREEMIUM:
Ah, freemium. The business model
that has dominated the 21st century. Whether
you’re trying to consume media, trade stocks,
or stream music, you can do it all for free.
You just need an internet connection. This was
one of the biggest revolutions brought on by
the internet. It made information, education,
and building businesses more accessible than ever
before. But more recently, there seems to be a
trend against free services. YouTube has managed
to garner 80 million paid subscribers. Apple Music
has managed to garner 78 million paid subscribers.
And even ProtonMail, a premium email client with
paid tiers, has managed to garner 70 million
users. Each and every one of these services has
a free alternative. Instead of YouTube premium,
you can just watch YouTube with ads. Instead of
Apple Music, you can just stream free Spotify.
And instead of ProtonMail, you can use virtually
any other email client. But despite this, more
and more people are choosing to pay for these
traditionally free services. In fact, it’s almost
become sort of a status symbol. Oh you still watch
ads on YouTube, what a peasant? This mentality
is especially prominent amongst the younger
generation of high schoolers and young adults.
But it goes beyond just superficial looks. The
reality is that there is no such thing as a free
service. If you’re not paying with cash, you’re
paying with attention, time, and/or privacy. And
as people become aware of this reality, the more
willing they are to reclaim their attention,
time, and privacy using cash. Companies are
even starting to use this as a pitch as to why
users should pay for a service. ProtonMail for
example proudly claims “Privacy isn’t free. Here’s
why that’s a good thing.” But, while I agree that
reclaiming privacy is a definitely good thing
for customers, it’s not exactly a great thing
for businesses. And I’m not talking about Google
or Facebook. This is great for them. If they can
just directly monetize their billions of users,
they no longer have to be the bad guy that’s
collecting and selling data. The companies that
this is bad for are the ones that are trying to
advertise on these platforms. Suddenly, everyone
who’s well off or even middle class are impossible
to reach making it exponentially harder to craft
successful ad campaigns. This could lead to a
pretty scary future for YouTube as advertisers
become more aggressive. So, join me as we take a
look at why free services are falling out of favor
and what this means for the freemium economy.
NEVER WORTH IT:
The bottomline is that free services are
never ever worth it. While it’s great that these
companies are able to offer their amazing services
for free, if you have to means to pay for the ad
free version or the private version or whatever,
you should always take it. The reason is that free
services are terrible at monetizing users. Yes,
platforms like Google and Facebook do make a crap
ton of money but that’s just because they have
mind bending levels of scale. On an individual
basis, these platforms make next to nothing.
And it’s no wonder why. There’s simply so much
friction when it comes to monetizing a free use
base. Take YouTube for example. Let’s say that you
watch about 1 hour of YouTube per day. Nowadays,
you usually get an ad once every 3 minutes and
each ad is about 10 seconds so you’re watching
about a 100 minutes worth of ads every month. Let
me phrase that in a different way, by not getting
YouTube premium for $12/mo, you’re essentially
selling your time for $7.20 per hour or basically
minimum wage in the US. Also, that’s if you do
it stupidly. The smarter choice would obviously
be to go for the family plan and split it with
your friends and family. The family plan costs
$23 per month and allows for up to 6 members,
so each member is only paying about $4/mo. So,
by not getting YouTube premium, you’re actually
selling your time for $2.40/hour and that’s if
you watch just 1 hour of YouTube per day. If you
watch 2 hours a day, you’re selling it for $1.2.
If you watch 3 hours a day, you’re selling it for
just $0.80 cents. And if you’re a YouTube addict
and watch 5 or 6 hours a day, you’re selling
it for just $0.40 to $0.50. Not to mention,
you’d be sitting through 10 hours of ads every
month. YouTube was an easy example but this is
the case with all free services. It’s impossible
for it to be any other way because of the physics
of the situation. For a normal service to work,
only 2 parties have to be happy. The business
and the user. For a freemium service to work,
three parties have to be happy. The business,
the user, and the monetizer. This is made worse
by the fact that most users don’t want anything
to do with the monetizer. I mean, who wants to
watch ads? This makes it especially difficult
for the monetizer to make the transaction worth
their time. And by extension, it also makes it
difficult for the business and the user to have
it be worth their time either. Back in the day,
users didn’t think consider this inefficiency
too seriously. As far as they were concerned,
they were getting media or email or news or
whatever else completely for free. But nowadays,
if you don’t know how these platforms make
money, you’re definitely living under a rock.
And people are simply coming to the logical
conclusion that giving up so much time, data,
and privacy just to save the $5 or $10 that
the service would’ve otherwise cost is stupid.
Now again, it’s great that you can access such
great services for free but if you can afford,
you should stay far far away from such deals as
they’re always a ripoff for everyone involved.
SOCIETAL SHIFT:
So, that’s kind of the logical argument as to
why people are ditching free services but this
shift is much deeper than a simple time vs money
relationship. The reality is that people simply
don’t trust free services. Back in the 2000s,
the average internet user might’ve thought: “Oh,
it’s just a website. How much could it possible
cost to run? That must be why its free.” But,
no one in their right mind thinks this today.
Everyone knows that internet companies are some
of the most profitable and wealthiest companies
in the world. So, how exactly are they making
this money and more importantly, where does
that leave the average user. Of course,
the average user would be giving up time, data,
and privacy but I don’t even think that’s what
annoys users the most. I think what annoys users
the most is the fact that they no longer have
a voice because they’re no longer the customer.
They’re the product being sold while the monetizer
is the real customer. This is what leads to the
disconnect between users and platforms that’s so
common nowadays. Oh, how could YouTube remove
the dislike button. Why does YouTube censor
great content just because its a little edgy. Why
did Robinhood halt GameStop. Do these companies
even listen to what their customers want? Well,
the answer is yes. These companies are very much
aware of what their customers want and they give
them just that. Advertisers want family friendly
content that they can get behind. As such,
that’s what YouTube pushes to the top. At first,
users will complain about it but eventually
they’ll get over it. Something that they don’t
get over though is the loss of trust. Users start
classifying these businesses as sell outs that
don’t even care about their customers. But the
reality is that the only way that these businesses
could have done it differently is if their users
were also their customers. So, naturally, people
have started to flock over to services where they
are the customer, where they feel valued. This has
already started to become more of a status thing
actually and you can thank Apple for that. Apple
is one of the only big tech companies who’s users
are actually their customers. And they’re very
much leaning into this. Just take a look at all
of this marketing material about privacy. Privacy.
That’s iPhone. Privacy Matters. Privacy.
That’s Apple. What happens on your iPhone,
stays on your iPhone. All of this is actually very
similar to that ProtonMail slogan that we we’re
talking about at the beginning of the video.
All of this enforces the idea that an ad free
experience and data privacy come at a premium cost
which you can get at Apple. And let’s just say,
people are eating this up. The iPhone has barely
changed over the past 5 years but the same cannot
be said about the iPhone’s marketshare. iPhone
marketshare has gone up substantially from about
a third of the US market to over half of the
US market. And as Apple continues to grow their
dominance, you can bet that people will only
be more inclined to pay to be the customer.
UNCERTAIN FUTURE:
So why are people ditching
free services? Well, people have simply come to
the realization that free services aren’t exactly
free and people are very much fed up with free
services and their ulterior motives. Personally,
I think this is great thing for companies and
users. Companies make more money directly from
the consumer and consumers get a better experience
while paying for exactly what they’re consuming.
It makes perfect sense but it’s not great for
everyone. It’s especially bad for advertisers.
You see, advertisers have already been getting
destroyed by the new age of media. On YouTube,
we’re literally complaining about 3 minutes
of ads for every hour of content. On TV,
it used to be like 12 minutes of ads for
every hour of content and it still is. It’s
just that no one really watches TV anymore. At
least, no one from the younger generations. So,
advertisers were already fighting for 4x times
less ad space but ad free offerings are just
making this exponentially worse. I mean,
who tends to pay for premium on YouTube,
or Hulu, or Netflix or really any platform.
Well, people who are well off and are able to
spend a little more on entertainment. And who
is the most likely to convert from ads. Well,
people who are well off and are able to
spend a little more on entertainment.
So, these ad free offerings are literally removing
the most valuable audience from an already limited
marketing pool. This leaves advertisers with only
one option. Target the content. This of course
means more companies doing sponsorships and paying
way more. We’ll also see more brand placement,
more affiliate marketing, more giveaways, more
brand deals, and all of the usual stuff but is
that where it’ll end? I’m sure you’ve noticed one
common thread amongst all of these. They’re all
skippable. Now, there are advantages to skippable
ads. Only people who are really interested in the
product will watch the ad and the advertisers can
get away with paying less. But, with that being
said, some advertisers will always be looking for
a way to push unskippable ads. How would they be
able to do this? Well, would YouTube ever push
out a feature that allows creators to show ads
even to premium members? You’re probably thinking
that this would be blasphomous. Why the hell are
you paying YouTube a premium price if you still
have to watch forced ads? Well, I don’t think
YouTube would necessarily make money from these
ads. I don’t even think it would necessarily be
feature that YouTube adds in on their own. Rather,
it could very well be a feature that creators ask
for due to how much brands are willing to pay.
They would probably justify it by saying that they
can make even better content if viewers watched
just one unskippable ad at the beginning of the
video. And then it’ll become 2 and 3 and 4 pretty
soon it’ll become just like mainstream TV. YouTube
will make money from the premium subscription just
like DirecTV or Dish Network. And then creators
will make money from ads and infomercials
just like TV channels and their shows. So,
is the trend towards premium subscriptions all
that great? Well, it really comes down to your
personal preference. Would you rather see higher
quality content with more ads or lower quality
content with less ads. Comment that down below.
Also, speaking of ads, YouTube recently blocked
adblock. This might’ve been one of the worst
decisions yet. Check out this video to learn more.